- And I would notice over the years,
no matter where I was working,
whatever market I worked in
and whatever station I worked for,
there was always that,
"Don't make the sponsors,
the people paying for
the commercials mad."
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today
is a former television news journalist
and now candidate for governor
of the great state of Arizona, Kari Lake.
Welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Hi, Dave.
Thank you for having me.
I'm so excited to be here.
- Kari, I have to start very obviously
my audience is gonna hear
former television journalists.
They're gonna freak out
because they don't like journalists.
Am I allowed to call
you a former journalist
without using air quotes?
Because, journalists these days,
I think you get it.
- Well, I came up through
the old school of journalism
where you told both sides of the story.
If there were three sides,
you told all three sides
and you kept your opinions out.
And that's why I walked
away from my career.
I started in journalism 30 years ago
and that's how you did it.
And now we've increasingly seeing
journalists moving on, out,
being replaced with propagandas.
And I was at the top of my game,
number one in ratings for pretty much
my entire time covering Arizona.
Most recently, 22 years
at the Fox affiliate,
number one, that whole
time making a fortune,
had a pretty good life.
And then COVID struck
and I realized there are no good guys
in the corporate media.
If there were good guys,
they would've covered ivermectin,
told us about hydroxychloroquine.
They would've been
honest about the election
and the corruption involved in that.
And I just...
I looked up in my career and said,
"Oh my gosh, I can't do this anymore.
I don't wanna be part of this."
It was getting increasingly more difficult
to be honest with the people of Arizona.
And if I couldn't speak 100% truth,
I didn't wanna be part
of it, so I walked away.
I do think there are some
good journalists out there.
The ones you're seeing
on the corporate media,
unfortunately, are mainly
propagandist today.
- Do you remember a moment
that you started getting
an inkling of all that?
Did it really start with COVID
or I suspect in 22 years,
you probably saw some other hints
leading to where we got to today?
- The news has increasingly been moving
toward the left, obviously,
over the past many decades.
And I just always felt like,
well, as long as I keep
what comes outta my mouth
and when I'm being a journalist,
I can keep that on the straight and narrow
and make sure that I'm being fair.
I can't always be responsible
for everybody else
that works in the industry,
but I know I can be for myself.
And I really truly felt
that I could do that
for the most part, almost all the time.
And so that's what kept
me going in my career.
There's always that, I guess,
it would be the law of
television broadcasting
and really any news entity,
they wanna protect their sponsors.
And I would notice over the years,
no matter where I was working,
whatever market I worked in,
and whatever station I worked for,
there was always that,
"Don't make the sponsors,
the people paying for
the commercials mad."
For example, if a big car company in town,
if there was a scandal somehow,
it was always pulling teeth
to get management to wanna
cover something like that.
They would maybe cover it if they had to,
but it would be a short
20-second version of the story
rather than covering it ad
nauseam like they would,
if it was somebody who wasn't a sponsor.
And looking back, you see things like that
and you go, "Wow, that's
a really dangerous thing,"
because we saw this during COVID.
These news outlets took
hundreds of millions of dollars
from Fauci and Big Pharma.
And you almost saw it happening.
You almost saw it like this,
like somebody flipped a switch,
and they all started talking
so positively about the vaccines.
And there was no critical coverage of it.
Now I'm not trying to be
judgmental on a vaccine,
but it is our responsibility
as journalists
to put out the truth
and not to tout a product,
and not to refuse to cover
the dangerous side effects
because the people are counting
on truth from journalism,
at least they used to.
And so when you see all these TV people
and newspaper people putting
out only the positives
and trying to shame
people into getting shots,
but not covering the true side effects.
And there are some very dangerous
side effects with these shots,
I believe they have blood on their hands.
And I'm so thankful that I got out
before that business started up,
because I was watching
that happen with horror,
knowing specifically people
who had terrible side effects
and actually blamed relatives
deaths on those shots,
and then sitting there
and watching journalists
tout them and pump them up
like they were the greatest thing.
I think it's disgraceful
and hinging on criminal.
- Are you amazed how
they can sort of do it
right in front of our eyes?
I don't know if you've
seen that compilation
that was going viral for a while.
We've shown it a couple times on my show,
where they show you all the
outros to the commercials,
the intros and outros to the commercials
on mainstream media,
CNN, CBS, Morning News,
et cetera, et cetera,
"Brought to you by Pfizer."
The same people who are telling you
how wonderful Pfizer is the entire time.
I thought at one time we were supposed
to be skeptical about this stuff?
- I saw that, I saw that compilation.
At first, I didn't believe it
'cause sometimes you see
these compilations and you go,
that can't be true.
- Yep.
- I was just watching.
I was leaving North Carolina a day ago
and I was watching one
of the major networks,
Morning Show,
and they were talking
about the teen suicide rate
and teen mental illness and all of that.
And they did a whole segment on it
and what to look out for.
They didn't talk about
what caused a lot of it,
which was these draconian shutdowns
and lockdowns and quarantines,
unnecessarily the
masking of our teenagers,
which wasn't needed and caused
all kinds of mental problems
and sending them home.
They didn't talk about that.
They just talked about how we've got teens
with a bunch of emotional issues now
and right out of it was an ad for,
I forget which big pharma,
about a drug for depression
and suicide and all of that.
- [Dave] Rexulti.
- And I'm like, wow,
it's so obvious once your eyes
are woken up to to it.
But some people just
aren't awake yet, Dave.
- Some people are not awake.
There's a lot of woke people,
just not a lot of awake people.
That seems to be the problem.
You did an event about two
weeks ago here in Florida,
I was gonna try to get there
and then something popped up.
But you were at Mar-a-Lago
with a certain orange man.
We'll play quick 10-second clip,
here is what he had to say about you.
- But I will say that I think
that's gonna be one of the great things
that I've done endorsing a woman
and helping her get elected.
And I think she'll go down
as the greatest governor.
(crowd cheering)
- All right, so it looks like you've got,
or not looks like,
you've got the endorsement of Trump.
You've done events with him.
How does that feel relative
to getting into politics
for the first time
and just the general state of craziness
on the circus that is
our political machine.
- Well, that sound bite
you just played was just...
It felt really good to hear that
because I do plan on
being the best governor,
best governor Arizona's ever seen.
Probably probably be the first governor
Arizona's ever seen that truly was in it
for the right reasons to represent
the great people of this state.
So when he said one of his
greatest accomplishments
will be to help get me elected.
And he knows I'll become
one of the greatest
governors in the country
that made me feel really good
because I'm in this for the right.
Trust me, there's no
reason you'd wanna get
into the corrupt world
of the Swampy politics,
unless you're doing it
for the right reason.
I'm not in it for the fame.
There's no money in it.
If you're an honest person
and you're not trying
to build the taxpayers
out of their money.
I'm just doing this
because I love Arizona.
And I looked at the field
of people who was running, Dave,
and I believe this is the
last election in this country.
If we don't get it right,
ad we don't get some America First people
in there running,
some honest citizen politicians,
I don't know that we'll have
a country beyond this election.
So I looked at the
field of who was running
and it's the typical
RINO career politician,
somebody who's run are, lost 20 years ago.
We have somebody who's run before
and run against Katie Hobbs,
who's gonna be the Democrat socialist
that we end up running against.
And he already lost to
her a few years ago.
So I looked at the field
of Republicans running
and I said, not a single one of them
can get us past the finish line.
And if we lose this election
and we get a Katie Hobbs,
who is a socialist Democrat,
we will lose Arizona.
And we cannot, as a country,
afford to lose another border state.
We'll be stuck with just Texas
holding the line for us.
And we need to get strong governors
in these border states
to hold the line for America.
We are about to lose our country.
If we don't have fair
elections and honest elections,
and we don't have a border,
then we do not have a country.
So this race is critical
and that's why I'm in it.
- So I wanna jump back to the border stuff
in just a sec,
but can you talk a little bit
about what generally
is going on in Arizona?
I think most people think of Arizona
and they're like,
"No, no, it should be a red state.
It seems like it's a red state,
but it doesn't fully
seem to be a red state."
It really, as you're
saying, could go either way.
It's a little hard to understand
what the electorate is
really made up of there
or where they're really going.
- Well, let me tell you Arizona
is as red as my shirt, okay?
It's a red state.
But when we have corrupt
elections that are stolen,
where we have mail-in ballots
being sent out to people
who don't even live here
and filled out and sent in
and we have ballot trafficking
and we have more voters
than even registered voters voting.
Then we're gonna have a corrupt election
that makes it look like
we aren't a red state.
And that's why it is imperative
that we get to the
bottom of this election.
And we do not allow another
election to be stolen.
It's not about Republican,
Democrat, independent.
It's about having honest elections
and saving our country.
So we're a red state. Absolutely.
We have a lot of people coming over
from California, believe it or not,
a lot of them are conservatives
who are fleeing they're political refugees
coming in from Oregon, and
Washington, California,
and other blue states.
And of course we do have some coming in
who are bringing their
liberal ideology with them
and we're really not interested
in becoming California.
So we are a very conservative state,
a Wild West state,
and we've got a issue with our border
that does not remain here in Arizona.
When we have people flowing across,
people being trafficked,
drugs being trafficked,
they move to other states beyond Arizona.
I was just in North
Carolina for the Trump rally
and the good people of North Carolina.
I think their number
one issue is the border.
They were chanting
"Build the wall, finish the wall,"
in North Carolina.
Think how far they are from the border.
This is an issue that
is an American issue,
not just an Arizona issue.
And we've gotta get a strong governor in
who is going to finish the wall,
send troops to the border,
and secure our border
for the rest of the country as well.
- How did this happen,
with the border, do you think?
I mean, we've been covering this a lot
and reading off the numbers
and it's gotten significantly worse,
under Biden obviously.
But what happened in Arizona and Texas
that allowed so much of this,
that allowed so many people to come in
and not just come in,
but they come in illegally
and then there's shipped to other states?
I don't know if you've seen,
but my governor here,
in Florida, DeSantis,
any illegals that they ship here,
he's shipping them to Delaware.
I highly recommend
(Kari laughs)
you Institute a policy like that
once you're governor.
But what do you think happened
in Arizona that led to this?
- Well, I have a better idea.
We're not letting 'em in the first place.
We're gonna keep them from coming in
and we're gonna find
them when they're here,
we're gonna send 'em
back across the border.
That way our tax money
is not going to pay for them.
What happened was Joe Biden.
And what happened before that
was a corrupt election
that got Joe Biden into office.
And Joe Biden came in and on day one,
he stripped back a border policy
that was the most effective border policy
I've ever seen in my 27
plus years of Arizona.
I covered Arizona for 27 years.
I covered the border
for all of those years,
and we never saw it better
than when president Trump was in charge.
He had secured our border,
the best I'd ever seen it.
And on day one, Joe Biden
came and tore that back,
completely exposed us
to a criminal element,
handed over control of our border
to Narco terrorists.
And they immediately started
to bring in people from
all over the world,
not just Mexico and central America,
people from 160 countries,
are pouring in, coming up
through our Southern border.
And Joe Biden's pretty much
giving them citizenship
by what he's done.
And it's gonna stop when I'm governor,
we are going to shut it down.
We're gonna finish the wall.
Have you seen the video
of all of that material
that we've already paid for?
I was just down there.
- [Dave] Oh, yeah.
- It's outrageous.
I was down there in Southern Arizona,
walking next to it, it goes on for a mile.
It's stacked up probably 20 feet high.
And it's just materials
for building the wall,
sitting there in the desert.
We're gonna take that back
under my border plan,
we're going to redefine what it means
to have abandoned federal property.
And we're gonna use
that to finish the wall.
We paid for it.
We paid for that material.
And we're also going to send
our Arizona national
guard down to the border.
We're gonna arm them
because we're not gonna put them up
against these cartel
members without arming them.
And we're going to have
them push people back
and not allow people to
come across our border.
If we catch them,
we arrest them for trespassing,
detain them, process them,
and send them back across the border.
And we do have the right to do that.
We're gonna ask other states
who are interested,
like-minded states to chip in and help.
Maybe they send their state guard down
and we will use them and utilize them
at the border to make sure
we have enough manpower on the border.
Our constitution allows for this, Dave.
The constitution, Article IV, Section 4,
the guarantee clause.
It requires the federal government
protect us from invasion.
And when they fail to do that,
in Article 1, Section 10, Clause 3,
the states have the power to take control.
It's almost state war power
to take control of their troops
and stop the invasion
which we intend to do beginning
on day one of my administration.
- Do you sense that that's
kind of the future of America?
Not just talking about
borders, but in general,
that will return to
some level of federalism
that we were intended to,
where the state that you live in
in some ways will be more important
than the federal government.
I mean, that's really the way
the whole thing was set up.
It doesn't seem to be the way
we think we're supposed to be governed,
but I sense that coming back.
I can tell you from living in California
for the last eight years
to where I live in Florida, right now,
it is like living in a
completely different country.
And I'm actually okay with that.
(Kari laughs)
- We're gonna learn the weak states
versus the strong states.
You could call it the blue states
versus the red states.
And I agree with you.
I mean, we realized during COVID
just how strong the states were.
We've handed over way too
much power, by the way,
to the federal government.
So it's about time
we bring that power back to the states,
but we learned when our governors
exerted their power
against the people during COVID
how much power they had.
Unfortunately they used
that power to torture us,
to shut our businesses down,
to shut our churches down,
to send our schools closing,
and sending our kids home.
They forced our kids to mask up.
They forced people to get
shots against their will.
So they use that power
in the most devious way, in my opinion.
I plan to use that power
to strengthen Arizona,
protect Arizona, and give
the power back to the people.
And you can see it as broad as daylight
when you go to Florida,
when you go to a red state,
when you go to a state like California,
where these terrible
radical leftist policies
have been in play for 40
plus years in California,
they've completely destroyed
what used to be a once great state.
And so I believe going back to state power
is the way to go,
to go back to our sovereignty.
We created the federal government.
They didn't create us.
And we are sovereign,
not serves of the federal government.
- What do your opponents say?
When you're talking to the Democrats
or if they're just talking about you,
maybe they're not talking to you, I mean,
what are they saying on the border that...
I mean, are they saying anything
that resonates with people
or that makes sense?
What is the policy of
a border state Democrat
at this point?
- Well, I'm actually impressed with...
That we're leading the charge.
My campaign is.
I've been on day one
talking about the border,
calling it an invasion,
calling it what it is.
And now my Republican
opponents are now jumping in,
even stealing parts of my plan,
which is fine because my plan
is the best plan out there
for securing the border.
So I'm actually pushing
just the entire discussion
on what we need to do
across the country even.
I've had other people
reach out to me and say,
"Can I take a look at your plan?
We might wanna implement it here."
I have sent it over to
our current governor,
Doug Ducey and said,
"Please implement this immediately."
We can't wait until I'm voted into office.
We can't wait until January 23.
We need to start this right away.
He never responded to that.
I hope, if he's listening,
that he will take a look at it
and implement it immediately.
It's the only way we can protect
the good people of Arizona and of America.
The Democrats of course are open borders.
I mean, they love what's going on.
They think that we should
be bringing everybody in
and taking on the world's problems.
And that is why it is so critical.
I think Arizona is the
most important state,
the most important governor's
race in the country,
because we cannot afford
to lose another red state
to these radicals on the left.
And I don't even wanna
call 'em Democrats anymore
because the Democrat party
from the JFK era is completely gone.
This is Marxism, socialism,
and they have every intention, Dave,
if they were to get into office,
completely seating the border
to the Narco terrorists and cartels.
And I cringe to think what would happen.
We'd have to all rent new
halls and escape Arizona.
- I used to think they were just inept.
And now I'm with you.
I think it's intentional.
You mentioned America First,
and that is the sort of
the Trump movement motto.
And I think Trump is obviously
trying to figure out
where he fits into that
with his political future,
perhaps, you know something
that people would like to know.
But what does America First mean to you?
I can sense on the border side,
but what does it mean broadly?
- It means putting the citizens
of this great country first
and that sounds like...
People go "Well, we do that."
No, we haven't been doing that.
For a full generation
the political elite have sold out America.
They sold out our companies
and our manufacturing overseas,
sent it to China.
And when they did that, by the way,
they started the destruction
of the American family.
I grew up in many in the 70s and 80s
in the Midwest, in Iowa.
At one point during the
80s, I remember almost
all of my friends' fathers got laid off.
They worked in manufacturing in plants,
and all of those plants got shut down
and they started to move overseas.
And that started the destruction
of the American family
because when your dad
loses a good paying job
and all of a sudden he can't find work
and it leads to substance abuse
and all kinds of issues,
it leads to just the,
I believe the disintegration
of the American family
and our communities.
And so we've been being sold out
for a long time by our political elite.
I don't know why they did it
if they were just trying to help
the next quarterly report
for the corporations
or if there was something in it for them,
but we've been sold out
by our political leaders.
And finally, when president Trump came in,
we saw what the America
First movement was.
It was about returning
business to America,
reassuring manufacturing,
putting the needs of our
American citizens first.
And I believe that is the only way
out the mess we're in,
restoring our freedoms to Americans.
During COVID, we watched
as people gave away their freedoms.
And we watched as people said,
"Okay, I'll mask up."
"Okay, I'll get the shot."
"Okay, I'll do that."
Every single time we give away a freedom,
we've gotta fight to get it back.
And we're at a point
where we're standing up and fighting
and we're gonna take it back.
We're at the 11th hour
to save this country.
And if we do not stand up
and speak out and risk being
canceled and persecuted,
who cares if they call you names,
we gotta stand up and fight
to take our freedoms back
and push these Marxists
to the edges and tell them
we don't want 'em anymore.
They're not gonna be controlling
our kids' curriculum.
our businesses anymore
and shutting them down.
We have to bring America
First policies back
and save this country. ,
- How nasty do you think that fight
between the America First crew
and sort of the RINO crew
or the Swamp crew
or the traditional
republic crew is gonna get?
I spend most of my time on this show
trying to expose the woke thing to people
and have people wake up and say,
"Hey, we can set aside
some of those differences on the right
and figure some of that stuff out."
But you can feel a fight
really brewing there
between the America First thing,
and whatever you want to call it,
the RINO, Swamp thing, whatever it is.
- Especially in Arizona,
there's remnants of the kind
of the McCain camp here still,
which is really RINO.
And we have RINOs like
Jeff Lake and all of that.
We have a pretty big
Swamp here in Arizona,
and they're on their last gasp of air,
but they are fighting.
The devil doesn't go down easy. (chuckles)
He fights back.
And so I'm really feeling it.
I mean, they're running attack ads on me.
They've been doing so since
August, when I jumped...
They realized when I jumped in the race
that I was a force to be contended with,
and that I was soaring in the polls,
they have poured millions of dollars
into this race to try to bring me down.
And this is the Swamp.
This is the Swamp not just from Arizona,
I found out that one of the guys
sitting on the Super PAC
running ads against me
is a RINO from Michigan who most likely
may have been involved
in that fraudulent election up there.
They're scared to death
to have a Trump Republican
who is bound and determined
to bring justice for our
corrupt election in 2020.
We're not gonna let people walk.
If they defrauded the voters of Arizona,
we find out who they are,
they will be held accountable,
and they don't want
someone like me in office.
So it's gonna be a
knockdown drag out fight,
but I've got a message for them.
I am a fighter.
And when I set my sights on something,
I make it happen
and I'm not afraid to be called names.
I'm not afraid for them to attack me.
I'm gonna stand tall for Arizona
and stand strong for Arizona.
And I don't care what they say about me.
We're gonna win this
and we're gonna get Arizona back on track.
And the days of the RINOs
and the Swamp are done.
Now I'm not saying I won't work
with an establishment Republican.
If they wanna come together
and work with the America First movement
and be all about making Arizona
the greatest state in the country,
then I'm all for it.
I wanna bring people together.
I wanna bring even Democrats
who are waking up to the insanity
of the left and this
fringe group on the left,
who are trying to drag this country down.
Those people who are waking up,
I want them on our team as well.
We need to grow this
conservative movement,
this America First movement,
and just finally do right
by the people of this state.
- You've mentioned election integrity
a couple times and fraudulent election,
I think you said.
It's funny, I had Blake Masters on
who is running for Senate
as a Republican at Arizona.
And he mentioned it as well.
Most people are afraid to talk about it
or don't wanna talk about it.
I suppose, YouTube
could blow up my channel
just because you put
those two words together
right then and there,
don't worry, I got some
backups, I'll be okay.
- Okay.
- But what is going on in Arizona
in terms of securing the election?
Or what were the things I suppose
that really set off the bells,
the alarms for you and
has anything been fixed?
And I ask that because the two candidates
that I've had from Arizona
have both brought it up.
- Well, we're not perfect yet.
We're not there for 22, no way.
I've been involved.
I've thrown myself into a
Arizona Supreme court case,
which unfortunately the
court decided not to take up.
I'm willing to risk everything
to make sure our elections are honest.
Some of the people in politics said,
"Oh, don't get involved in that
'cause you're trying to get rid
of mail and ballots and mail
and voting is very popular."
And I said, "I'm not trying
to do the popular thing.
I'm trying to do the right thing."
And so I jumped into that case.
Unfortunately, the Arizona Supreme Court
didn't have the courage to take that up.
I'm getting involved in an injunction
that we're gonna ask for
an emergency injunction
against these corrupt voting machines.
And I'm not afraid to
jump into this fight.
This is a fight worth taking.
This is a hill worth dying on,
because if we don't have secure elections,
we can't accomplish anything.
We can't make sure our
kids' curriculum is secure.
We can't make sure our border is secure.
If they're installing people into office
and we're not getting
the people we actually vote for,
then we've lost our country.
So we did get some legislation passed
that is going to require you
to show proof of citizenship,
basically, an ID and a
social security card.
Right now we had 16,000 people
on our voter rolls who
had no driver's license
and no last four digits
of their social security.
That is an indication
they were probably illegal voters.
And there were 16,000 of
them on the voter rolls.
As you know, Joe Biden only allegedly won
by just over 10,000 votes.
So that's the margin of victory,
I guess, you could say.
We have a ton of problems.
We've had millions of
election files deleted.
We have election and state
laws that were broken.
We have 740,000 ballots
that had no chain of custody.
Those should be voided out ballots.
If there's no chain of custody,
they need to be voided out.
And they were counted.
President Trump,
I believe won Arizona by a landslide.
And I'm not trying to be
the typical politician
who always says the things
that the consultants want you to say.
I'm not doing that.
I am saying what is true.
And I was talking to president Trump,
he was kind of chuckling.
He said, "I love you never back down
from a fight and you could ask Kari
what the weather's like.
And she'll somehow find a way
to talk about the stolen
election in Arizona."
(Dave chuckles)
But we have to do that
because stolen elections have consequences
and all of the troubles
we're facing in this country, Dave,
stem from that corrupt rigged election.
- Are you worried that
a certain set of people
just don't wanna talk about it,
or I guess more so are just
afraid to talk about it
because they don't want channels deleted.
They don't wanna get banned
from Twitter and Facebook
and everything else,
that as righteous as you may believe it is
that it's just like one of those things
where people are just like,
"Ah, we gotta move on."
Something like that.
- We can't move on.
I mean, I wish I wish it were that easy.
Honest to God, I wish we could say that,
but we can't.
If we do move on that next election
will be the selection.
It'll be rigged.
And then the next one
rigged, and there we go,
we're not a country anymore.
So we can't move on.
But that being said,
we're gonna do everything we can
and we're gonna fight to make it right.
We're gonna fight to make it on this.
So I'm not worried about being censored.
I have been censored before.
I think more information's
going to continue to come out.
In Mar-a-Lago and we
saw the movie "Rigged,"
which David Bossie put together
with Citizens United,
really important movie talking
about the Zuckerberg
money that was poured in.
We can't have that.
We can't have a billionaire tech tyrant
pouring in almost half a billion dollars
to get Joe Biden elected.
This is wrong.
This needs to be outlawed,
that kind of money being poured in
for one candidate basically.
And we're about to see the 2000 Mules
come out in Dinesh D'Souza's movie.
And I think that's gonna
be a real eye opener
for the people of this country.
And if we can just get
some honest elections in there
and get some people who wanna get in
and make sure that we
get the laws in place
to make sure every election
going forward is honest,
then we're gonna have, I think,
great policies moving forward
and we'll have great elected officials,
not these lifelong losers
who we have in office right now.
- Are you telling me that the 450 million
that Zuckerberg spent
wasn't just to be nice
that he might have had a
intention with that money?
(Kari laughs)
- Yeah, that's exactly
what I'm telling you.
He wasn't trying to help president Trump,
let me put it that way.
Neither were the folks in the media
who ran just attack piece,
hit piece after hit piece
on Trump and refused to cover Joe Biden's
or I should say his
son's laptop from hell.
It's just been nonstop.
That's really where it first started
for me in the media.
I started to see my colleagues
and all of the media
start to lose their mind
when president Trump came on the scene
and that's when I realized,
"Wow, there are seriously
biased people here
who are trying to destroy this president
who is a transformative
president trying to help."
- Can you talk about some
of the energy around that?
Because I went to a
Trump rally by accident,
I actually happened to pass
a Trump rally in Beverly
Hills, right by rodeo drive,
Pretty Woman rodeo drive
in the summer of 2020.
I wasn't publicly supporting
Trump at that time.
I was kind of going in that direction,
but I had never seen it,
but I go to one of these rallies,
he wasn't there.
It was just the Beverly Hills Trump rally.
And I saw what was the happiest,
most joyous, music, dancing,
American flags everywhere,
truly diverse in the
right sense of diverse
thing I had ever seen before.
And that was one of the things
that finally sort of got me
over the hump related to Trump.
You've been in there in the middle of it
with the energy and all that.
Can you talk about just
what that thing is like?
- It is amazing.
It is such a beautiful show
of patriotism and love for America.
Of course, everyone at those events
loves president Trump.
He's the reason they're there.
But you're watching people,
and I was just in North Carolina
at the most recent Trump rally.
You watch people show up early.
It's not easy to get to these places.
Sometimes they're in out of the way towns
and they drive a long time to get there.
They park a long way back.
They walk. They're there for hours.
I'm talking seven, eight, nine hours.
Sometimes it's cold.
This isn't just a light level
of commitment to president Trump.
This is a deep, deep commitment
and love for a man who put them first,
to put working class Americans first,
who put our families first,
who put our rights first.
So this is a deep love.
And if people think that
the Trump movement is gone,
they've got their head buried in the sand.
It is alive and well,
and it is growing by the day.
I almost get a little emotional
when I get to these sometimes
because I look out at the sea
of Americans who love America.
And doesn't matter what
color their skin is,
doesn't matter what their religion is,
doesn't matter where they came from.
They might be immigrants.
They might have parents
who are immigrants.
They might be seventh
generation Americans.
And they're there because the thing
that binds us together
is that common thread
that we love America.
And that's why the left
and radicals on the left
are trying to destroy that
and make patriotism.
And they're trying to make love
for America a bad thing.
They're trying to brainwash our kids
into hating America
through the perverted
history they're teaching.
What you see at a Trump rally
is just pure love for
this beautiful country
that we have to save.
It's the most amazing country in the world
and we can't let it go.
And I just love that I'm watching
this movement grow and
that people are waking up.
- You talk about history.
What would you do on the education side?
'Cause obviously so much of
this is related to education.
We're watching kids be either
intentionally indoctrinated
at public schools
or intentionally indoctrinated
by world corporations like Disney.
What would you do on the schooling side?
- Oh, well we're about to
put out our education plan,
but I can tell you right now.
First of all, I signed
the Hillsdale 1776 pledge.
That's the kind of education
we should be teaching our kids,
not this woke garbage.
and I have two children,
one graduated last year from high school.
I've got one who's still in high school.
So as a parent, as a mom,
I'm deeply concerned
about the curriculum that's being taught.
And I think really one of
the ways to solve that,
one of the simplest ways
and president Trump has talked about this
is you fund the student, not the school.
So it puts power back into
the hands of the family,
gives the family power
over where they wanna send their kids.
And if you find out that you're sending
your son and your daughter
down to the school down the block
and they they're teaching CRT
and they're teaching your
kids to hate America.
And they're teaching your kids
to question their gender.
You can and say "No, no, no, no, no."
We're pulling our kids out
and we're gonna bring 'em to this school
and the money follows your child.
And when that happens, I will tell you,
in a very short order, these schools,
mainly the government run schools
are gonna shape up.
They're gonna realize
they're losing enrollment
and they're on the verge of extinction
if they don't shape up
and teach our kids curriculum
that actually makes sense,
teaches them to be prepared
for the real world.
It's called competition, right?
If all of a sudden the kids
are all leaving your school,
going to another school,
you're gonna have to make
some adjustments or you're gonna go under.
- Do you think they're too
damaged to turn around?
I'm with you on that you fund students
instead of systems for sure.
More private schools,
more charter schools,
et cetera, et cetera.
Do you think there's any chance
even if they saw a
massive drop in enrollment
that the public schools
would have some value or could come back?
- Well, if they don't,
they'll go the way of
the dinosaur. (chuckles)
I mean, if pretty soon
nobody wants to come to your school,
it is gonna be pretty hard.
It's gonna be pretty hard to stick around.
I'm a big proponent of homeschooling.
I think we need to support
our homeschool families.
They've been kind of
left out of the equation.
I'm on the campaign trail.
I'll tell you what,
homeschooling is growing.
It's growing at a very rapid clip
because people were tired
of having their kids
school shut down.
And then when they went back to school,
they had to abuse the
children with these masks.
So I'm a big proponent of homeschooling.
And I think we need to
support them as well,
but we need to get really
serious about the curriculum.
My plan calls for...
At 10th grade, after 10th grade,
we put our kids on a
track, a career track,
whether they're gonna go
to a four-year college,
a vocational school,
whether they wanna get
a trade skills learned
and we can have our kids
graduating at age 18,
as senior in high school
with a plan for a job.
I was just at a school down in Vail,
which is down in a Tucson area
and they have a welding program
they started at their school.
And these kids are being hired
before they even graduate high school.
Obviously they're finishing high school,
but these companies are coming in,
offering them 70 to 80 plus,
70 to 80,000 or more
to take on welding jobs.
They're learning that
skill in high school,
they get full benefits,
they can actually raise a family someday
with that kind of a salary.
We need people in the trades really badly.
And those are the skills that I think
our boys want to do.
Even our girls want to do those,
but I look at sometimes the way
we educate our boys.
And I'm a mom to a boy.
And I know sometimes he
would rather be in a class
where he's learning how to weld
or he's learning some
sort of a trade skill
and his mind and his
hands are being worked
than sitting there listening to a lecture,
especially if a teacher's
droning on about CRT
or switching genders.
We gotta get our kids
ready for the real world.
- Boys like thing.
Girls usually like people.
It's reality.
It just is what it is.
We got a couple minutes left.
So I just wanna get a couple
more in, somewhat quickly.
So okay, we fix some of the border stuff.
We fix some of the school stuff.
So now let's say you're governor
it's February, March 2023,
and Fauci calls you and says,
"Time to mask everybody up again.
Time to shut it down again.
Time to socially distance again."
How's that call gonna?
- I don't think he'll call me.
I mean, I was the one at the Trump rally
when I spoke that said
"We need to lock that guy up."
Frankly, we should.
I mean, he's lied
if you've read Robert F.
Kennedy Jr's book on Fauci.
I think I have it sitting
right here behind me.
- We've got it here.
- It's called "The Real Anthony Fauci"
here, right here. (chuckles)
I'm not being paid to pitch this,
but every journalist in America
should be digging through that
and doing stories on this man.
He has been more harmful to our health,
that health of this country
than probably anybody.
And frankly, this is not hyperbole,
I think the man should
be locked up and charged
for what he did during COVID.
The lies. He lied to Congress.
He lied to the American people
and I would love to see him
and facing the music for that.
And, and maybe an arrest
warrant out for him.
Hopefully, maybe in
Arizona, we can do that.
And then he won't wanna take a road trip
through Arizona and stop
at a pit stop for a bathroom.
We might haul him in.
So we're not gonna do it.
In Arizona, we're not
shutting this state down.
I wanna make it perfectly clear.
As governor of Arizona,
I will never shut a
business down over COVID.
I will never shut your churches down.
I will never shut the
schools down over COVID.
And I will never mask our
children again over COVID
and we're gonna get it to a point,
where people aren't losing their jobs
because they refuse to
get one of these jobs
that Fauci has been probably
making a fortune off of.
So we need to get things set straight
for the good, hardworking
people of this country.
And we are not gonna be taking a cue
from Anthony Fauci,
no way, not in Arizona.
- I actually I don't think
we can end an interview
any stronger than that.
I think you're not messing
around with that guy.
- Let me just say,
Dr. Fauci, don't call me.
(chuckles) You don't wanna
have that phone call.
It's not gonna go well for you.
- Fair enough. Fair enough.
Well, listen, I am about
to embark on a book tour.
I am gonna be in your fair state
at the Tempe Improv.
What's the date on that one guys?
Around May 15th, 16th,
something like that.
We're gonna send you an
invite and if you could-
- [Man] 16th
- May 16th.
I am at the Tempe Improv
- Awesome.
- and if you're in town
and you wanna come on stage
and talk to the people,
I'd love to have you.
- That would be great.
- So I thank you for
doing this and good luck.
- Thank you, Dave.
Thanks so much. Appreciate it.
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell.